Entertainer of the Year I mean you can
take home all the rewards what does it
mean to be all right now Kevin you start
any trouble don't get ahead of myself
how about doing that thing you do right
what was that uh that it's going viral
now yeah
Viola Davis my woman king that's okay
you're a genius and Jamie Lee you are
all of us what does that mean to you you
don't fun is fun it started one way and
then it took a turn in a matter of hours
and days and now it's it's it's just a
lot of fun and I'm enjoying it I'm
enjoying it
everybody here tonight it feels like the
image Awards have finally found their
rightful home on BET and that how
important is this because you know we
look at what's going on with the
nominations and everything this year how
important once again are the emissions
oh you know it's just a place called
home you know absolutely well we've been
celebrating each other and ourselves
um when when and and everyone needs to
we are looking for representation and
validation for the wonderful work that
we do and sometimes it's hard to come by
you know but but the nfcp has always uh
celebrated us we celebrate each other
yes we do tell me about this outfit real
quick
oh beautiful black designer of course
read a Constantine so I love it and I'm
warm yeah and how about this guy right
here I just want
I'm pointing at you I'm pointing at you
I'm pointing at you man I love this man
this is such a great night you know and
important to celebrate our culture
you know and and
Blackness you know we're here to
celebrate every year we come here but
this year is very special to me because
of that one there so I'm just excited to
be that you should see our countertop
it's just full you know so I'm just I'm
just excited to just be here and be and
celebrate her I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm ready
no no you're right we're ready yeah I
want to celebrate her and us all of us
there is something so magical about this
woman in the glow that you see around I
know so I see it all the time but I'm
it's it's her time it's her season it is
her season it's her season it is her
season what did the girl say about me
she said get a girl you give me my blood
by pressure get a girl her things give
her her things
please forgive him but he is right this
is your supporter I love it